how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe lately there has been
a
ton of hype around spider-man 3 and the
multiverse
of course the one division series is
going to be exploring the multiverse and
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness of course we'll explore it as
well and with new reports about the
movie coming out just about every other
day now i thought i'd make a video
simplifying everything and putting all
of these reports together to talk about
everything that we know about spider-man
3 and the mcu
and there's a good chance that some of
these reports in here you probably
haven't heard before
but from the multiverse to dr strange
showing up from everyone knowing that
peter parker is spider-man to sony
telling us that we're going to be
getting a trailer
by the end of the year here's everything
we know so far about spider-man 3.
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you stay up to date on all
the latest
mcu and spider-man 3 news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a black widow funko pop from the
avengers game i'm picking a winner on
friday
so there has been just a ton of
information that is rumored or reported
about spider-man 3 so let's just start
out simple
we know for a fact that spider-man 3 is
going to pick up right where spider-man
fire from home left off
when we last left spider-man and
spider-man 5 from home in the
post-credits scene mysterio
pegged him out to be a murderer and he
revealed his identity as peter parker
and this is right where we're going to
pick up in spider-man 3 and this
is confirmed by some league set photos
and set videos
having said that there are some
characters and actors who are confirmed
to be coming back for the third
spider-man homecoming film
zendaya is returning to take on the role
of mj
jacob battle on is returning to take on
his role of ned
and peter parker's best friend marisa
tomei is returning as aunt may and tony
revolori is returning to play flash
thompson and based off of what we know
at least from the beginning of this film
peter parker is going to be on the run
but this movie is going to be a lot
bigger and a lot different than any
other spider-man film that we've seen
before
and this is confirmed by executive
producer amy pascal
in an interview last year with
comicbook.com she confirmed that they
were considering titles for the third
spider-man film such as spider-man home
run or spider-man homeless
but she also said and i quote so you
never know
he might be a fugitive he's going to be
in a very different place and
it's a different story than we've ever
told before you have to keep changing
these movies because
there's only so many times it can be to
be spider-man or to be
peter parker so right off the bat we
have amy pascal
executive producer for all of the
spider-man homecoming films telling us
that this movie is going to be very
different
and if all the reports that we've heard
recently are in fact
true we know why it's going to be very
different and of course that is
the multiverse now when it comes to
spider-man 3 and the multiverse we've
got
a lot of reports from some pretty
credible sources and if you're somebody
who likes to stay up to date on all the
latest scoops specifically
involving spider-man 3. daniel rpk has a
lot of great scoops on his patreon you
can just go to patreon.com
danielrpk for some awesome spider-man 3
scoops and other marvel dc and star wars
scoops as well and from what we've
learned spider-man 3 is said to be an
avengers
in-game level multiverse movie and this
is reportedly because sony is the one
who pushed for this
evidently when spider-man 3 first
started out it was supposed to be a
simple craven the hunter film turned
into a huge
multiverse film and this is because one
division we know is going to explore the
multiverse and so is doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness so
what we get now is a huge spider-man 3
multiverse film and there have been
reports
left and right about spider-man 3 being
a multiverse film from daniel rpk from
grace randolph and from a bunch of other
insiders but even if you ignore the
reports from the insiders there's still
proof that it's going to be a multiverse
film
and this is because of two people jimmy
fox and benedict cumberbatch
it's been confirmed that jamie foxx will
be playing max
dillon aka electro from the amazing
spider-man films
and of course it's been confirmed that
doctor strange is going to have a key
role in spider-man 3 as well
so two reasons why it's going to open up
the multiverse and spider-man 3.
one jamie foxx previously played a
non-marvel cinematic universe version of
electro in amazing spider-man 2
and 2. doctor strange is confirmed to
explore other universes in his upcoming
film
multiverse of madness and a recent
report tells us that there's a very
specific order for
three key films in the mcu one division
spider-man 3 and then doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness so one
division is going to start us off
exploring the multiverse just a little
bit spider-man 3 will take it even
further and then doctor strange
is going to have to clean it up and of
course it's worth noting that sam raimi
who directed the original spider-man
toby maguire trilogy
is the director for multiverse of
madness so it does seem like things are
coming full circle here
now what will the multiverse hold in
store for peter parker we're not
exactly sure yet however we do have many
reports stating who could show up in the
multiverse
of course as i mentioned before jamie
foxx is confirmed to be returning as
elektro
and then we have doctor strange
returning and according to reports he's
going to be peter parker's mentor now in
spider-man homecoming of course tony
stark was peter's mentor
then in spider-man far from home even
though tony was gone he still had a
couple of mentors at first
mysterio was kind of a mentor to him at
least that's how peter saw it at first
but once it was revealed that mysterio
was a villain he then had happy to take
on that role of a mentor
and now he's going to have doctor
strange in the third spider-man
homecoming film
and now of course getting into the big
multiverse rumors here it has been
reported that toby maguire
will be returning and reprising his role
as peter parker
and spider-man in spider-man 3 in the
mcu
and a report from daniel rpk suggests
that this peter parker toby maguire's
peter parker may be acting as an uncle
ben type figure
for tom holland's peter parker how
exactly this will play out we'll have to
wait and see
but it's also been reported that kirsten
dunst is also in talks to return to
reprise her role as
mj in spider-man 3 in the mcu and just
last week we got the report that alfred
molina is in talks to return as doc op
as
well now doc op did die in the sam raimi
trilogy so we're not exactly sure how
he's going to return but with the
multiverse anything is possible
then shifting universes to the amazing
spider-man universe we also had the
report that andrew garfield is going to
return and reprise his role as peter
parker and spider-man as well
now along with this report comes another
report that andrew garfield is a little
bit shaky and hesitant to return to play
peter parker
because of how people treated him when
he played spider-man in the amazing
spider-man trilogies
so from what we've heard this isn't a
100 yet
but we have also heard that emma stone
is in talks to return
and reprise her role as gwen stacy now
this is another situation much like doc
op where she's actually dead in the
universe that she was originally in
but again anything is possible with the
multiverse
and last but not least from the amazing
spider-man universe it said that the
green goblin could return
as well and then we have a really big
one there has been reports that a miles
morales has been cast
for the marvel cinematic universe or at
least marvel studios is currently
in the process for casting a miles
morales now at this point it is unclear
whether or not this is
for spider-man 3 or if it's for a
different project even a miles morales
solo film
but since we have so many other
spider-man reportedly appearing in
spider-man 3 it would make sense that
they would include
miles morales in there as well then we
have the report of
the sinister six now before there was
talks of the multiverse the sinister six
was the big hype of the film
are they going to show up and who
exactly are going to make up
the sinister six well there are still
reports that the sinister six
are going to show up but now the reports
have slightly changed the sinister six
still could show up
but it's rumored that the villains could
actually be from different
universes so we could have doc op from
one universe
the green goblin from a different
universe and vulture scorpion and others
from our main universe
right now this is more of a rumor than
an actual solidified report but
considering the fact that jamie foxx's
electro is coming from a different
universe it does have merit to it
and would make sense for the film if
you're going to have multiple spider-man
in a film you're going to need a lot of
villains as well
and speaking of villains he was
reportedly supposed to be the original
villain for this film
craven the hunter since the multiverse
plot has come out we really haven't
heard much about craven the hunter but
if he was originally supposed to be the
main villain we can assume that he's
going to be in this movie in some way
shape or form
presumably he'll be one of the members
of the sinister six
and last but not least as far as
villains are concerned there have been
rumors that norman osborne a real
norman osborn from our universe is going
to show up
now in spider-man far from home we saw
that the old avengers tower is being
reconstructed
somebody has bought that building and
will hopefully find out who exactly
bought it in spider-man 3.
and right now we really have two main
options and that of course
is norman osborne and it's going to be
oscorp or it could be the baxter
building
and this is going to be how they
introduced the fantastic four
now we know the fantastic four are
coming kevin foggy has already
officially announced this
but with so much already happening in
spider-man 3 it's hard to believe that
they would
also introduce the fantastic four so if
i had to pick
one of the two to actually happen in
spider-man 3 it's most likely going to
be norman osborne and ozcorp
and the last update we have about
spider-man 3 is a possible return
of charlie cox as matt murdock aka
daredevil now this past sunday the
rights to daredevil have officially gone
back to marvel studios
and there's been a lot of talk lately
about marvel studios using him in the
actual
mcu and i could think of one person in
particularly who
really needs a lawyer and that would be
our boy peter parker
now this is just speculation at this
point right now there's nothing
confirmed
and with so many characters already
appearing in spider-man 3
adding daredevil may bring it over the
top but perhaps a quick cameo from
charlie cox as matt murdock
in a simple scene where he's peter's
lawyer perhaps at the end of the film
could set up daredevil for future films
and is entirely possible
however i wouldn't hold your breath and
so far that's everything that we know
about spider-man 3 and the mcu lots of
reports and lots of rumors but one thing
is for sure is that if even half of
these things do come true spider-man 3
is going to be an insane movie so let me
know what you think about these reports
and rumors for spider-man 3 in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest news
happening in the mcu for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof